l'adhérent on a parlé de quelle morale
devait être programmé dans les
intelligences artificielles on a vu en
particulier le concept de volition
cohérente
extrapolé de façon grossière la vo lu
tion cohérente extrapoler c'est la
morale que nous autres humains voudrions
avoir si nous étions capables de penser
plus l'engouement de façon plus juste et
avec plus de données fiables bon si nous
sommes qu'il est pas tout à fait
rigoureuse et il y aura encore beaucoup
de choses à dire à ce sujet mais on va
supposer pour aujourd'hui quand on a
réussi à programmer 99 99% de cette
morale dans unir est ce que le problème
de la morale désir serait résolu pour
autant
et bien malheureusement la réponse est
non ou du moins pas si on a réussi à
résoudre le problème de la programmation
de la morale de lire qu à 99.99 %
seulement je vous présentais le monde y
est même dit doctorant à le pfl qui fait
sa recherche en sécurité désir et comme
le dit mehdi résoudre le problème à 99
99%
c'est ne pas l'avoir résolu oui parce
que du coup ça veut dire que l'ia
pourrait complètement se louper 0,01
pour cent du temps sauf que les ja
d'aujourd'hui prennent des milliards de
décisions parfois par seconde comme
quand il s'agit de recommander des
vidéos sur youtube or 0 0 1% d'un
milliard ça fait cent mille décisions
potentiellement catastrophiques comme
recommandé une vidéo sexuelle d'un
enfant
une invitation au suicide à une personne
déprimée ou une vidéo anti vaccins à une
jeune maman qui cherchent des français
pour son bébé et ça c'est juste youtube
dans un futur potentiellement à ses
proches
il ya pourra être aussi en charge d'un
grand nombre d'opérations à grands
risques comme la conduite de véhicule
autonome les problèmes de santé et
l'exploitation de ressources pour
pouvoir être implémentée en pratique il
y as devra être robuste aux erreurs et
ses quelques erreurs devront pouvoir
être rectifiées rapidement et
efficacement dans le jargon on dit que
lille devra être tolérante aux fautes
en fait c'est même pire que ça vu le
rôle central que joly a dans le futur il
ya de très grandes chances que les
utilisateur malintentionné cherche à
exploiter les failles de l'ia est
d'ailleurs cette remarque n'est pas
spécifique à lla comme on a déjà
longuement parlé dans la série sur
démocratie dans des systèmes complexes
avec de nombreux utilisateurs
il est primordial d'anticiper les
incentives de ses utilisateurs
car c'est incentive peuvent amener les
utilisateurs à user de toutes sortes de
comportements y compris des
comportements immoraux pour
arriver à leurs fins par exemple les
jours de football vont profiter des
facultés limitée des arbitres humains
comme par exemple leur inaptitude à
toujours repérer les simulations ce sens
ces failles des arbitres humain qui
pousse les joueurs à effectuer des
simulations
bien sûr ces simulations ne fonctionne
pas toujours mais les quelques fois où
elles fonctionnent elles risquent de
changer drastiquement le cours des
matchs alors dans le cas du fou qu'il
s'agit de problèmes pas existentielle
encore que une simulation qui conduit un
penalty en rien de coupe du monde ça
peut générer de la haine dans tout un
pays et ainsi conduire à des millions de
déçus mais quand il s'agit de problèmes
de santé d'environnement ou de sécurité
les enjeux sont tout autres imaginons
par exemple que les contrôles de
sécurité à l'aéroport soit désormais
géré par des intelligences artificielles
cia sont capable de scanner vos bagages
en rayons x et de déterminer mieux que
les humains si vos bagages contiennent
des armes dangereuses et imaginant que
les humains ont un taux de réussite de
90 % alors que l'isaf ont un banc 99
points 99 % est ce à dire que les ja se
rend plus sûrs que les humains et bien
pas forcément en effet le problème c'est
que même s'il y a plus souvent raison
que l'humain pour des bagages pris au
hasard
il reste néanmoins possible que des
terroristes arrivent à systématiquement
piéger les ja
alors que ces mêmes terroristes auraient
du mal à systématiquement piéger les
humains et malheureusement ce genre de
défaillance des ia semble omniprésent
dans les ia d'aujourd'hui en effet de
nombreuses études montrent que les
meilleurs y analyse d'image quand des
performances surhumaine et pourtant il
est généralement possible de modifier
les images analysées de manière
imperceptible pour les humains tout en
amenant l'intelligence artificielle a
complètement se foirer dans
l'interprétation de l'image en question
comme dans le cas d'une bombe qui selon
une intelligence artificielle sera
perçue comme une tortue et là je fais
référence à une étude par des étudiants
du mi6 qui ont imprimé en 3d des tortues
des fausses tortue et réussi à les faire
passer auprès d'une intelligence
artificielle de google pour des armes à
feu on peut très bien imaginer linverse
ou des périodes de terroristes
fabriqueront des armes à feu qui seront
perçues par des intelligences
artificielles de report comme des
bagages anodin et je vous renvoie vers
l'épisode 20 avec lg ji hoon a vu en
quoi la malédiction de la
dimensionnalité semble être une cause
majeure de cette défaillance désirs ses
façons d'exploiter ces failles d
intelligence
filles elles sont appelées les attaques
par évasion une attaque par évasion ça
consiste à bien connaître les
intelligences artificielles qui nous
affecte et à bidouiller légèrement nos
données pour que ces ziya classifie nos
données de manière erronée est bon quand
ce sont des vidéos youtube ça peut
rendre quelques annonceurs publicitaires
mécontents mais quand il s'agit dizaine
de voitures autonomes ou de médecine
assisté par désir
le problème des attaques par évasion
peut-être tout à coup une question de
vie ou de mort
de telles attaques peuvent amener les ya
à voir et à entendre des choses qui ne
sont pas là ce qui peut ensuite causé
des accidents et donc des morts suivis
de décès est en fait aujourd'hui une
grosse partie de leurs recherches en ir
consiste justement à réduire la
vulnérabilité désir à ces attaques par
évasion
ceci dit il existe des attaques
potentielles non plus redoutable encore
que ces attaques par évasion
souvenez-vous unis là c'est avant tout
une machine à apprendre des données
qu'on lui fournit mais alors si un
hacker veut vraiment faire des
fonctionnaires unia il lui suffit
d'attaquer de données d'apprentissage
là encore l'analogie avec les humains
est assez évidente si vous voulez que le
peuple croit quelque chose que cette
chose soit vraie ou fausse
alors vous pouvez long convaincre en
l'exposant à certaines données plutôt
qu'à d'autres typiquement si vous voulez
que le peuple croit que la logique du
premier ordre avec tiers exclu soit le
fondement de tout savoir rigoureux alors
vous pouvez l'en convaincre en
l'éduquant à la sauce bourbaki c dès son
plus jeune âge et si vous voulez le
convaincre et que seule la démocratie
est légitime
vous pouvez vanter les mérites de
démocratie dans tous les médias comme
l'humain ce que pensera lia dépendra
fortement de ce à quoi
l'ia sera exposée or de nos jours cia
ont tendance à piocher leurs données du
web d'internet s'est donné sans bien
trop nombreuses pour être filtrées par
un humain pire encore des hackers pour
est volontairement biaisé les données du
web en y mettant faut se donner des
sortes de fake nous aussi on veut
utiliser le terme typiquement si vous
êtes profondément anti vaccins vous
pourriez vouloir partager sur les
réseaux sociaux sur youtube et sur
wikipédia défaut grave indiquant toutes
sortes de corrélation entre vaccination
et d'autres données unia qui apprendrait
de twitter de youtube et de wikipédia
pourrait alors avoir un apprentissage
biaisé par vos données et conclure que
ces vaccins ont un effet nocif sur la
santé en parle d' attaque par
empoisonnement pauline attaque sangle
puisque d'une certaine manière les ja se
nourrissent
des données et que l' attaque consiste à
empoisonner la qualité de ces mêmes
données or comme le dit l'adage de
l'informaticien garbage in garbage out
autrement dit si vous donnez de la merde
à unia elle vous ressortir de la merde
ce qui est vraiment problématique c'est
que bien souvent une seule donnée
empoisonné peut complètement pourrir
l'apprentissage de lire par exemple si
vous cherchez à apprendre une régression
linéaire alors en modifiant l'ordonné
d'une seule donnée d'entraînement un
attaquant peut vous amener à apprendre
une corrélation négative au lieu d'une
corrélation positive
typiquement en ne modifiant qu'une seule
donnée d'apprentissage d'unir on peut
t'amener unis a à apprendre que
l'utilisation des vaccins est corrélé
négativement et donc à un effet négatif
sur la santé
moi j'aime bien donner l'analogie
suivante imaginez une salle remplie de
chercheurs universitaires en train de
déclarer leurs revenus et unia veut
apprendre grâce à cet engin échantillons
la fortune typique d'un chercheur
universitaire sauf que dans la salle
passé par a par erreur un milliardaire
qui remplissaient lui aussi sa fiche de
revenus l'ia qui fera des raisonnements
par moyenne déduira que les chercheurs
universitaires sans des
multimillionnaires parce que la moyenne
d'un milliard et de quelques milliers ça
fait des centaines de millions l'ia qui
résonnera par médiane par contre elle ne
se trompera pas le revenu typique d'un
chercheur universitaire est bien de
l'ordre du millier d'euros ce que la
médiane c'est la valeur qui se trouvent
au milieu du classement
et si on classe plusieurs milliers et
milliers milliers milliers milliers
milliers puis un milliard le moule à la
moitié de la médiane sera toujours de
l'ordre du millier de façon générale
nous algorithmes d'apprentissage naïf ne
sont absolument pas robuste à ce genre
d' attaque par empoisonnement pour
contrer les attaques par empoisonnement
il est important d'anticiper le fait
qu'une certaine proportion des données
ne sera pas fiable est typiquement une
façon de se faire est de remplacer les
calculs de moyennes par des calculs de
médias à l'instar de ce qui a été
proposé par le jugement m'ingérer
majoritaire dans l'est a parlé dans un
épisode de sa série sur la démocratie
dans le cadre de la régression linéaire
ceci correspond à remplacer la
régression linéaire classique par
moindres carrés par une minimisation des
déviations absolue notamment défendue
par le grand la place la place comme
déjà parus dans l'épisode 9 et de façon
plus générale il semble indispensable de
concevoir des algorithmes
d'apprentissage qui partent de là priori
que certaines des données reçues seront
complètement et
au nez voire biaisé et qu'il faut donc
absolument s'autoriser à ne pas les
expliquer tout ça pour dire les ja
doivent développer elle aussi un esprit
critique pour soigner leur hygiène
mentale
enfin une dernière cause potentielle de
dysfonctionnement des ia est un
dysfonctionnement au niveau de certains
de leurs composants surtout au fur et à
mesure que l' architecture des unités de
calcul désir sera de plus en plus
décentralisée en lan servent de plus en
plus les meilleures intelligences
artificielles modernes utilisent souvent
plusieurs cartes graphiques pour
paralyser leurs calculs voire plusieurs
centres de données distinctes pour ne
pas avoir à transporter ces données qui
est une opération très coûteuse en
termes de temps et d'énergie
c'est typiquement ce que fait lia de
youtube qui doit être au service 2
milliards d'utilisateurs
cependant dans des systèmes complexes
décentralisée il est improbable qu'aucun
des composants ne se mettra
dysfonctionné pire un composant peut
être à quai et ce encore portement peut
être contrôlé par un individu
malveillant
les systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
moderne se doivent alors se doter
d'algorithmes d'apprentissage résilient
face à toutes sortes de disques ans
fonctionnement de leur proposant on
parle alors de tolérance aux fautes
byzantine en référence aux travaux du
prix turing 2013 leslie l'emportant et
il y aurait tellement plus à dire sur
ces notions d'algorithmique distribuer
et de fautes byzantine
mais ça nous éloignerait un petit peu
des problèmes dire de notre série
bref comme vous l'aurez compris au fur
et à mesure que lié à déployer à grande
échelle de nombreux problèmes de
sécurité et de résidences à toute sorte
d'attaqué se pose or il nous gouvernent
en fait déjà
il ya donc urgence à adresser ses
problèmes de sécurité désir j'espère que
j'avais aimé cette vidéo un grand merci
à mehdi qui est doctorat le pfl c'était
pas facile comme exercice est donc merci
à lui d'avoir osé participer médias
justement récemment publié une série de
trois articles dans les très grosses
conférences en machine learning que son
hystérie récit mails sur des
probablement de l'agrégation de
l'information on lit à différentes
données et le tout en étant robuste à
des attaques byzantine notamment sur les
données qui sont fournis en disant des
idées comme la médiane plus tôt que la
moyenne
donc si vous voulez en savoir plus et
savoir comment on peut rendre des ia
plus robuste à des attaques par
empoisonnement ben je vous recommande
vivement d'aller lire ces articles il
faut être motivé parce que ces articles
des recherches
bédié est aussi celui qui a lancé le
projet one dida qui est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai été embauché à le pfl donc
c'est un peu beaucoup grâce à lui que
j'ai le job kg aujourd'hui est donc que
plus rarement si vous voulez en savoir
plus sur les principes de base machine
learning ou même des mathématiques de la
physique ou de l'informatique
je vous le recommande à l'éthique et
webdesign comment certaines vidéos café
midi sur la chaîne wanted à l'anr fois
on a parlé de l'évolution cohérente
extrapoler et fument ils nous demandent
si ce sylvie salaire tout beau tout rose
mais est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas des
défauts vocation les alternatives alors
des alternatives
oui il y en a pardon peut penser à
l'utilitarisme ou à n'importe quelle
forme de conséquentialiste où les
valeurs des différents états du monde
son entrée à la mort par un humain on
pourrait aussi imaginer que pour chaque
décision de l'iea il ya un vote
démocratique pour savoir ce qu'il y a de
faire sauf que bien sûr ça pose pas que
as for games et ce vote et ça va prendre
un temps fou
plusieurs jours que d'organiser un vote
à l'échelle nationale ou internationale
et du coup ça voudrait dire qu'il ya ne
peut prendre aucune décision par
plusieurs jours ce qui est vraiment pas
satisfaisant puisque on aimerait des
gars qui prennent des milliards de
décisions par seconde ont tué c'est ce
que font déjà les yeux d'aujourd'hui
bref c'est pour dire que les
alternatives aux civils il y en a mais
elles sont souvent quelque chose d'assez
insatisfaisant en tout cas où entre
l'utilitarisme et 6,8 j'hésite pas une
seconde de l'utilitarisme semble très
très dangereux si on en plus menthe dans
une intelligence artificielle et du coup
c'est un vrai prennent très difficile
que de programmer la morale izia est
pour l'instant à ma connaissance il n'ya
pas d'autre alternative très crédible je
dirais que sylvie est vraiment de loin
aujourd'hui ce que je trouve le plus
convaincant et ça c'est un point très
important si vous voulez critiquer le
sylvie et ben il faut aussi de critiquer
par rapport à une alternative et du coup
je pense qu'on n'a pas assez réfléchi à
ce problème pour faute comme moi
personnellement j'ai vraiment pas assez
réfléchi à ce problème pour l'instant
pour dire que sylvie est la seule
solution possible mais c'est la seule
solution que j'ai cru parmi celles que
j'ai croisés qui est vrai qu'il me
semble vraiment convaincantes quant à
savoir si sylvie à des défauts bah oui
il y en a il y en a malheureusement
énormément le principal défaut d'eau
civis et que c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement difficile à calculer et
qu'il faut certainement une intelligence
artificielle pour calculer le sivi un
humain ne pourra pas exprimer par
lui-même le sivi c'est un calcul très
compliqué que d'y arriver à ceux ci vit
donc même unia ne pourra pas avoir une
bonne réponse aussi vie elle ne pourra
avoir que des réponses probabiliste est
approché du coup je pense que c'est très
important typique manqué plusieurs ia
qui soit en charge de calcul et le suivi
est typiquement on va prendre la moyenne
ou la médiane de ces différentes aux ja
et ça pose également beaucoup d'autres
problèmes de la cage et tout ça quand on
m'a parlé dans la vidéo que vous nettoie
tous ça pour dire que implémenter le
service est un problème extrêmement
difficile et puis l'autre problème c'est
de nous convaincre nous humains que
sylvie calcul vraiment ce qu'on aimerait
qu'on calcule calcul c'est à dire que
c'est vraiment un suivi que lydia calcul
vraiment le sylvie et ça c'est
extrêmement difficile de nous convaincre
humain sans doute que les ja vont devoir
faire preuve de pédagogie
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'après son
meilleur que du mans pour y arriver mais
bon soit six meilleurs quasiment pour
nous manipuler d'une certaine manière
nous faire croire qu'elle calcule aussi
vie donc je pense pas qu'on puisse
vraiment faire confiance à une ia qui
nous explique calcul e cie vie
tout cela rend le problème du contrôle
interne les i en coop est extrêmement
compliqué moi j'étais ans avancé que le
problème du contrôle désir est tout
simplement sans espoir est qu'il faut
vraiment juste essayé d'implanter un
suivi et au moment
de la mise en place de l'architecturé du
système de 7 hier de niveau humain il
faut déjà que tout serait sera en place
sinon moi j'ai mes repères que je suis
très très très pessimiste quant à
l'avenir de l'humanité si on ne fait pas
tout ce travail pour s'assurer qu'une ya
deux niveaux humain et des valeurs
humaines étant donc implémente un truc
comme le seuil du prado demande aussi le
mois puisse plus exister nécessairement
et s'ils sont tous d'accord a priori
s'il devait parier je dirais que les six
mois puisque ce ne seront pas tous
d'accord sur tout tout cas il y aura des
points de divergence peut-être des
points de divergence assez important ce
qui importe en france pour prendre une
morale les ja d'autant de sécurité de
l'humanité c'est que au moins le sylvie
soit fin du mois puisque plus lorsqu'ils
sont d'accord le civil le sait c'est
vraiment la priorité
essayons au moins d'être sûr que l'on
est d'accord sur certains points par
exemple torturé début et à des fins
récréatives c'est mal ça serait bien que
le civil eux pensent aussi je veux et je
pense à prédire que mon mois + + va
penser que torturer des bébés à des fins
récréatives c'est mal aussi
après quant à savoir si le mois + plus
ça existe vraiment non c'est une
construction de la pensée donc il
existera jamais dans le monde physique
c'est une expérience de pensée imaginer
qu est-ce que moi si j'ai beaucoup plus
de temps de réfléchir je prenais
beaucoup plus les rudiments de toutes
les philosophies science et que je
faisais ça que je préfère qu'il me
semble la plus fiable et sûr ensuite
j'ai utilisé tout tout tout tout ses
connaissances et j'avais accès à toutes
les données possibles et que je prenais
vraiment le temps de méditer à chacune
des données à méditer à chaque enfant en
afrique typiquement qui monte barres de
fer entre moment si je prenais le temps
de réfléchir à tout ça qu'est-ce qu'elle
kazan serait vraiment les conséquences
il faut qu'on ait vraiment tout le temps
de la réflexion et avec toutes les
données qui sont possibles ou est-ce que
je reviendrai et sa typiquement c'est un
exemple de bond contrefactuelle et c'est
quelque chose qui est très bien traitée
par certaine philosophie du savoir en
partie payée par le mécanisme pour le
bayer zanis il suffit de décrire l'état
du monde de rajouter quelques bribes
d'informations sur la modification de
l'état du monde et de demander ensuite à
aubagne et à nice
de prédire qu'est ce que je voudrais
typiquement sinon dans cette danse au
monde de contractuels et ça c'est une
question qui est qui qui a une réponse
si on prend un cadre bayésiens cool moi
plus plus peut être prédits par un cadre
bayard ce qui est important à voir c'est
que le belize à nice mme fait toujours
des prédictions probabiliste est donc le
mois puisse plus même dans le cadre du
mécanisme sera plein d'incertitudes
et du coup il ya une incertitude sur la
morale du mois + plus si je pense qu'il
est très important de prendre ces
emplois en compte
mais qu'est cette incertitude
épistémique d'ailleurs je sais pas
comment moi j'évoluerai je peux faire
des prédictions mais je ne peux pas en
être sûr et en plus une incertitude due
à la construction du moi plus plus quel
est l'ordre dans lequel le mois + + voix
ont analysé les données qu'on lui donne
tout ça fait qu'il ya des couche
supplémentaire d'incertitude qui font
que on est fondamentalement dans
l'incertitude quant aux préférences du
moins perçues c'est très important à
prendre en compte alors je renvoie vers
la dernière vidéo de sa fille où il
parle un peu de cette incertitude
épistémique sur nos moral et quand on
prend ça en compte sa force à prendre
les décisions aujourd'hui par exemple
comme explique thibault si une
probabilité 1% que j'attribue une
certaine valeur drastique un certain
événement par le risque existentiel
alors que mon à 86 ans je prends ça je
pense que c'est n'importe quoi et que
j'attribue aucune valeur morale en plus
serré cela s'il suffit d' qui est un pur
sang de valloire épistémique que en
effet le mois puce puce attribue une
grande importance à quelque chose à ce
moment là quand je calcule l'espérance
de la valeur morale de telles actions
ça doit rentrer en compte et le fait que
c'est une grande ampleur peut faire
faire en sorte que j'agis selon une
morale qui me semble très peu probable
mais parce que les effets les valeurs
morales associées à cette morale ont des
grands effets je vais quand même lui
donner beaucoup d'importance
c'est un magnifique roman d'ailleurs je
vous renvoie vers la vidéo de thibault
et sur ces questions là essayer surtout
de ne pas être ou liga ne pas avoir un
avis prédéterminé que vous voulez
défendre
essayez d'écouter avant l'argument de me
suffit qu'il n'est pas du tout
spécifique aux sujets qu'ils traitent
qui est un argument absolument
meirieu et essayer de réfléchir
calmement et sereinement à la morale
voilà si vous êtes un peu tendu à
exciter pas à l'aise au moment de
regarder cette vidéo c'est que c'est pas
le moment de répondre à la vidéo
sessegnon ne pas laisser un commentaire
c'est le moment de prendre sur vous de
réfléchir au calme de prendre le temps
de la réflexion et de lutter contre le
week-end en vous enfin ce n'est pas à
nos bols de la chaîne aux homos fabius
qui avait déjà fait une collaboration la
vidéo ici fait la remarque que
finalement ce n'est peut-être pas plus
mal
en tout cas selon lui ça serait mieux si
la morale et il a été adapté à la morale
des gens de l'époque où l'ia est
appliquée en ce sens du coup la morale
des deux ya de vrais accolé à la morale
descriptive
moi personnellement c'est quelque chose
qui me met très très très mal à l'aise
parce que je pense que on est à chic
moralement en tout cas moi
personnellement il ya plein de choses
que je pensais il ya un an que je ne
pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya plein de
divergences comme ça et j'ai vraiment
l'impression de progresser moralement et
je pense que chaque année qui passe et
du temps perdu dans typiquement par
rapport à la malaria voit la malaria ya
un an où il ya deux ans c'est c'est un
problème que je ne considérais pas
important alors qu'aujourd'hui je
considère que c'est un problème
extrêmement important qui tua
littéralement des décès des centaines ou
milliers donc ces sept cent mille morts
par an qui touchent des centaines de
millions de personnes par an des
centaines de millions de personnes
souffrent chaque année à cause de ça
c'est une fraction très importante de la
population de même façon je pense que la
vieillesse aujourd'hui quelque chose
d'atroce comme ça ça me fait vivre des
décennies dans des facultés réduite à la
fois physique et mentale donc je pense
que ses rangs des catastrophes
aujourd'hui et c'est quelque chose que
je ne pensais pas il ya un an ou deux
ans et du coup je pense que la morale du
mois d'il ya un an est vraiment très 0
n'est que je n'avais pas du tout le sens
des priorités et je pensais important
des trucs qui en fait voilà par exemple
éducation de mathématiques en fait c'est
très très secondaire du coup je pense
que c'est très important que l'on fasse
mieux que notre moral d'aujourd'hui et
je trouverais même cela immoral que
d'utiliser la morale d'aujourd'hui pour
tourner décision sachant qu'elle est
très très très erronée c'est pour ça que
pour moi le c'est très important de
faire mieux
je sens que moi du présent et très
ignorants 13 irrationnelle et qui l'a
faut sur beaucoup de points et qui l'a
surtout une énorme marge de progression
son moral est typiquement par rapport à
moi de l'année dernière je pense avoir
déjà énormément progressé tactiquement
avec la vidéo de thibaut de la semaine
dernière m'a fait pas marrer penser
certaines choses notamment avec ses dix
et deux mois plus plus aussi des
concepts très récent pour moi et je
trouve ça indispensable que quelqu'un en
charge au finalement de la société soit
dans cette optique plutôt que dans
l'optique du mois du prison de morale
descriptif de ce que moi aujourd'hui je
préfère qu'ils aient vraiment on
convoque pas du tout souhaitable
j'ai très peu d'attachement ma morale du
mois du présent ce qui m'intéresse c'est
bien plus la morale du mois puisque plus
et je pense que c'est une attitude qui
est indispensable à voir lorsque l'on
parle et qu'on pense à la morale et
qu'on raisonne sur la morale civique moi
je pense qu'un des aspects importants de
moi puissent plus y des deux mois
puisque c'est que lorsque vous cherchez
à débattre quelqu'un le but ne doit pas
être de le convaincre
le but ça doit être de l'amener à
réfléchir à ce qu'on puisse plus et à se
rapprocher de son opus plus j'aurais
tendance à dire que un bon débat c'est
un débat dans lesquelles les personnes
qui débattent se rapprochent de leur
mort puisse plus malheureusement en
pratique c'est pas trop ce qui se passe
elle espère que j'avais mais cet épisode
là proviendra on va continuer à parler
de sécurité désir va continuer à
considérer déjà et dont la morale est
bien programmé à 99 80 % voire même à
100% et on va voir que même saisi à
peuvent continuer à dysfonctionner si on
ne réfléchit pas suffisamment étions
simplement pas suffisamment un système
bien conçu si vous avez aimé cet épisode
santé à le like est le commentaire de
partager pense à vous abonner pour les
futurs épisodes martiaux tipper cordon
et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine toi work and grab des inputs
images des snipers trimestre car si mal
[Musique]
venu